Salut !
Comment on peut faire
pour manipuler des souvenirs ?
Quel est le hasard qui a
permis de découvrir l'anesthésie,
qu'elle soit locale ou générale ?
Comment on peut
changer des choses
dans le cerveau des adultes,
comme des enfants ?
Comment les chiens ont permis
de mieux comprendre
le cerveau d'un être humain ?
Voici un tout petit aperçu
de ce qu'on va voir aujourd'hui,
dans l'épisode 3, des expériences
stylées sur le cerveau.
Episode 3, parce que vous
avez masse liké et visionné aussi,
l'épisode 2, l'épisode 1,
en demandant dans les commentaires,
un nouvel épisode.
Donc c'est le cas, donc si
vous voulez un épisode 4,
vous savez ce qu'il vous
reste à faire.
Loïc, générique.
- Peut-être.
- Non, générique.
- Peut-être !
- Générique !
Tu vois, à cause de toi,
je suis agressif.
[Musique]
Vous avez déjà tous lu
un article de journal,
qui relate un événement,
dans lequel la victime
d'une agression,
quel que soit
le type de l'agression,
précise que personne
autour d'elle n'a bougé.
Alors que le lieu où ça s'est passé,
il y avait du monde partout.
Que les personnes
voyaient, entendaient.
Et pourtant personne
ne réagissait.
En temps normal comme moi,
vous étiez révolté lors de la lecture
ou de l'écoute de ce fait divers,
en vous disant :
"Mais moi, si j'avais été là,
j'y serais allé direct et j'aurais réagi".
Et pourtant,
au final c'est pas si sûr,
que nous, on aurait été mieux
que les autres personnes.
Alors pourquoi
et comment changer ça ?
C'est un phénomène
qui a un nom.
Et qui a été
clairement identifié.
Il s'agit de l'effet du spectateur
ou l'effet témoin.
Ou encore l'effet
de Kitty Genovese.
En 1968, Kitty Genovese
qui est gérante d'un bar à New-York,
se fait poignarder
devant 38 personnes.
38 personnes quand même.
Autant de personnes qui restent
les mains dans les poches,
qui ne réagissent pas face
à l'horreur qui se passe devant eux.
Suite à ce drame,
il y a deux psychologues.
Le psychologue John Darley
et Bibb Latané,
qui ont décidé de faire
une expérience.
Alors voilà
comment ça se passe.
D'un côté, ils isolent dans des pièces,
seulement deux personnes.
L'un des participants
est un ou une complice
qui va simuler un malaise
au bout de quelques minutes.
Pour l'autre participant,
c'est aussi un autre participant.
Et dans d'autres pièces,
ils réunissent quatre participants.
Et encore un ou une complice,
qui va simuler exactement
le même malaise.
Donc d'un côté,
il y a des gens en binôme.
Participant plus complice,
qui fait semblant d'aller pas bien.
Et de l'autre côté,
quatre participants
plus complice qui fait
semblant d'aller pas bien.
Et qu'est ce qu'ils
nous disent les résultats ?
Les résultats ont montré
que les personnes
qui étaient seules
avec la victime, le complice,
sont beaucoup plus susceptibles
de réagir ou d'aller demander de l'aide,
que le groupe
de quatre personnes.
Dans le groupe
de quatre personnes,
chaque individu se repose
sur le fait que d'autres personnes
sont présentes et considère donc
que quelqu'un d'autre
que lui va réagir en premier.
Mais évidemment,
si tous les spectateurs de la scène
se disent la même chose
inconsciemment.
Alors la pauvre victime sera
peut-être dans un état critique
avant que l'un
d'entre eux ne réagisse.
Et ce phénomène se produit
partout dans le monde,
à chaque instant.
Un malaise-voyageur
dans le métro,
un vol à l'arraché
dans la rue,
une petite mamie qui galère à monter
ses escaliers avec ses courses.
Là c'est pas dramatique,
mais si on est plusieurs,
on va tous se dire :
"L'autre à qu'à le faire" ou
"Peut-être l'autre va le faire".
Du coup pensez-y,
et soyez toujours le premier
ou la première à réagir.
ça donne une impulsion au groupe.
Et puis s'il n'y avait pas de danger,
vous allez être joyeux
pour la journée,
parce que vous aurez
aidé quelqu'un.
Et s'il y avait danger,
vous avez peut-être changé
vraiment le cours des choses.
Parce qu'il suffit qu'une seule personne
réagisse et interpelle le groupe,
pour que le groupe
se mette en marche.
Donc maintenant,
vous avez vu cette vidéo.
Et maintenant que moi aussi
j'ai fait ces recherches là,
soyons les personnes
qui réagissent en premier.
Avant de vous parler
des neurones Q.
Je vous jure Loïc,
les neurones Q existent.
- Okay.
- Je vous vouvoie, parce qu'on est
dans une vidéo de science.
Et les scientifiques
se vouvoient, Monsieur Loïc.
- Très bien Monsieur Fabien !
- Agent L, c'est vous ?
Donc avant de parler
des neurones Q,
on va parler de Ivan Pavlov,
un médecin Russe,
qui a mené une expérience qui
semble hyper simple sur des chiens,
mais qui a révolutionné le travail
sur les réflexes conditionnés.
Vous en avez peut-être
entendu parler.
Mais je vais faire
peut-être des ajouts.
Dans un premier temps,
Pavlov fait des recherches
sur la salivation des chiens,
pour un programme
de recherche sur la digestion.
Ni plus ni moins.
Il incise la joue
des chiens en laboratoire,
pour mettre un tuyau
qui va récolter la salive
directement depuis
la glande salivaire.
Et il va analyser la récolte.
Alors, on est bien d'accord,
on a déjà parlé de ça
dans les autres vidéos.
Autre période, autre déontologie,
autre respect de l'animal.
Pavlov glisse ensuite de la viande
en poudre dans la gueule du toutou,
afin de récolter et analyser
de nouveau la salive qui en résulte.
Suite à ces expériences,
Pavlov observe que le chien
qui revenait dans son laboratoire
pour la suite du programme,
commençait à saliver
dès qu'il voyait la pièce
dans laquelle ils entraient
et à la vue du plat
et les sachets de nourriture
qu'ils allaient avoir.
Ils reconnaissaient ça.
Ils commençaient déjà à saliver.
Et Pavlov, il est pas bête,
il a compris que le stimulus
qui a entraîné la salivation
n'était pas directement la nourriture.
Mais les événements qui
précédaient le moment du repas.
Et que le chien reconnaissait
comme étant le moment et le lieu,
où il allait être nourri.
Il en est arrivé à la conclusion
qu'il s'agissait là,
de la base de l'apprentissage.
Et a nommé ce phénomène
le réflexe conditionné.
En effet, il existe
plusieurs choses.
Des réflexes neutres,
en réponse à des stimuli neutres.
Tel qu'une clochette
qu'on viendrait faire sonner
et qui ne produit pas
de réflexe particulier.
Des réflexes inconditionnés,
qui sont des réponses
à des stimuli inconditionnés.
Comme le fait de saliver à l'odeur
d'un plat cuisiné par exemple.
Si on sent cette odeur là,
il s'agit alors d'un réflexe,
qui ne nécessite pas
d'apprentissage.
On sent, on salive.
Et là Pavlov arrive,
il nous dit qu'il existerait donc
des réflexes conditionnés,
en réponse à des stimuli,
qui à la base étaient neutres.
Tels que la salivation,
à l'activation d'une clochette.
Il s'est dit, est-ce qu'il serait
possible de créer ce réflexe,
à partir d'un stimulus
que je vais choisir ?
Je crois que tout à l'heure au pluriel,
j'ai dit stimulus au lieu de stimuli.
Du coup vous allez quand même
corriger dans les commentaires.
Ainsi est née
la seconde expérience,
qui est la plus concrète
et plus "dog friendly".
Avant de servir
la nourriture à ces chiens,
Pavlov a utilisé une clochette qu'il
faisait sonner comme ça, juste avant.
Dans un premier temps,
le son de la clochette ne produit
aucun effet sur les chiens.
Mais comme il recommence à
chaque repas, sans aucune exception.
Le stimulus neutre
devient alors quelque chose
qui rentre dans
l'inconscient des chiens,
pour devenir
un stimulus conditionné.
Juste, il faisait sonner cette clochette
et les chiens commençaient à saliver.
A la suite des études de Pavlov,
un autre psychologue Américain,
John Watson a également fait
une expérience de son côté.
Alors là, c'était pas très cool
pour les enfants ce coup-ci.
Il a appelé ça,
l'expérience du Petit Albert.
En fait, Watson offrait une souris
blanche à un enfant, qui était ravi.
Pas pour longtemps,
parce qu'à chaque fois que
l'enfant s'approchait de l'animal,
Watson faisait claquer deux règles
entre ses mains très fort,
pour créer un son très fort
et pour effrayer le petit enfant,
qui se mettait à pleurer.
Et au fur et à mesure,
à force d'entendre le son au moment
d'atteindre la souris pour la caresser,
l'esprit de l'enfant associait
directement le son à l'animal
et finit par avoir peur
de la souris blanche de Watson.
Et aussi de Watson
directement au passage,
parce qu'il savait très bien
que c'est lui qui faisait ça.
Mais même sans Watson,
juste avec la souris, l'enfant avait peur.
Watson avait réussi à créer
une phobie chez un enfant.
Et elle était si forte
que tout ce qui ressemblait,
de près ou de loin,
à de la fourrure blanche.
un lapin blanc,
la barbe du père Noël, etc.
Faisait peur à l'enfant.
Et ce qui fait peur,
c'est de voir comment on peut
travailler le cerveau d'un être humain.
Lorsqu'un neuroscientifique
voyage à Milan,
l'un de ses passe temps favori,
c'est de visiter la Piazza Del Duomo,
Duomo ? Duomo.
Eh Giuseppe.
Pourquoi tu lèves la tête,
tu t'appelles Giuseppe ?
- Oui.
- C'était ton vrai prénom ?
- Mais...
- Et maintenant, je le sais.
- Oui c'est moi !
- Tu as été cherché si loin,
ton accent !
Bref, ils vont visiter
la place du dôme.
On peut y voir
une magnifique cathédrale,
qui fut érigée au 14ème siècle.
Mais c'est pas le principal attrait,
pour les scientifiques qui viennent.
En fait en 1978,
c'est cette place qui a été utilisée
par deux neuropsychologues.
Edoardo Bisiach
et son élève Claudio Luzzati,
dans une expérience
menée sur des personnes
atteintes d'Héminégligence.
Mais alors c'est quoi
l'héminégligence ?
L'héminégligence ou
la négligence spatiale unilatérale,
c'est le fait pour un patient d'occulter
tout ce qui se passe à sa gauche.
En gros la vision
des patients est parfaite.
Mais lorsqu'ils mangent,
ils vont pas toucher le côté
gauche de leur assiette
Lorsqu'ils se rasent,
ils oublient de raser
la partie gauche,
qui reste alors poilue.
Lorsqu'ils ou elles se maquillent,
ils vont couvrir que
la partie droite du visage.
Bref, pour ces patients tout
ce qui se passe du côté gauche,
n'existe pas.
C'est plus qu'oublier,
ça n'existe pas.
Enfin au départ,
on croyait que c'était oublié.
Et c'est ce qu'on pensait
avant l'expérience
menée par Bisiach et Luzzati.
En 1941, Walter Brain
mène une expérience
sur un patient
atteint d'héminégligence
et remarque que ses déplacements
sont également atteints.
Il est incapable
de tourner à gauche,
si son itinéraire prévoit
qu'il doit tourner à gauche.
Donc Brain conclut qu'il s'agit
d'une perte de mémoire topographique.
Mais un détail n'a pas été révélé
par le scientifique.
Le patient décrit avoir croisé
sur son chemin des bâtiments
et d'autres monuments,
qui se situaient sur sa droite.
Alors qu'en fait, ils se trouvaient
en réalité sur sa gauche.
Ce qui remettait
clairement en question,
l'idée d'une perte de mémoire
ou d'un oubli complet.
Sceptiques sur le fait que,
l'héminégligence serait lié
à une perte de mémoire.
Edoardo Bisiach et son élève donc
Claudio Luzzati demandent en 1978,
à deux de leurs patients
de décrire de mémoire,
la place du dôme de Milan,
qu'ils connaissaient très bien.
Et donc dans un premier temps,
ils leur demandent de s'installer
dans leur tête, au bout de la place.
Donc face à la cathédrale.
Et là comme prévu,
les patients décrivent tout
ce qui se rappellent en fait.
Et donc tout ce qui est
à droite de la place.
Jusque-là, il n'y a rien d'anormal.
Et ils leur demandent maintenant
de s'imaginer mentalement,
se mettre dos à la cathédrale,
donc de l'autre côté de la place.
Et là on pourrait penser qu'il s'agit
d'une opération impossible
pour les patients puisqu'ils
vont logiquement décrire
tout ce qui se trouve
du côté droit,
exactement la partie
qu'ils n'ont pas pu décrire
depuis l'emplacement précédent.
Et là surprise.
Ils décrivent sans aucun problème,
tout ce qu'ils se rappellent
qui se trouvait à leur droite.
Mais cette fois-ci,
très logiquement,
ils oublient de décrire
tout ce qu'il y a sur leur gauche.
Alors qu'ils viennent de le faire
quelques secondes avant.
Est-ce que vous
me suivez bien là dessus ?
Pourquoi je trouve ça fou ?
Tu suis ça Loïc ?
- Je suis comme eux,
j'attends la révélation.
- L'expérience se poursuit
avec l'un des deux patients,
en lui demandant de décrire
son propre bureau dans sa vraie vie,
dans lequel se trouve
notamment un piano.
C'est quand même pas un truc
qu'on oublie, un piano.
Et bien selon l'emplacement mental
du patient dans son bureau,
pour le décrire,
le piano disparaît et réapparaît.
Selon comment il se met
et selon où il regarde dans sa tête.
Et cette étrange expérience
de la Plaza Del Duomo,
a donc permis d'annihiler,
la théorie de Brain.
Et de reconsidérer la pathologie,
comme un trouble
d'accès à la conscience,
plutôt que comme
une perte de mémoire.
En gros, ils n'ont pas accès
à l'information à ce moment là.
Et c'est pour ça que le mec
décrit son propre bureau,
où il y a quand même
son piano à lui.
Suivant où il est, il dit :
"Bah voila, j'ai tout décrit".
Non il n'y a pas un piano ?
Non.
Non, il n'y a pas
de piano dans mon bureau.
Parce qu'il n'a pas accès
à cette partie là de la conscience.
Elle existe, mais il a besoin d'être
dans une certaine situation
pour y avoir accès.
Alors on n'est pas encore
aux neurones Q,
mais on va parler
de protoxyde d'azote,
grâce à Horace Wells,
qui est un arracheur de dents,
de l'état du Connecticut.
Qui avait à l'époque pour ambition,
un jour de pouvoir réparer les dents.
Au lieu de les arracher.
Parce qu'avant,
un soigneur de dents,
c'est quelqu'un qui les arrache,
c'est tout.
Et le 10 décembre 1844,
il aperçoit une affiche
qui parle d'un spectacle
qui aura lieu le soir même.
Et qui promeut
l'utilisation d'un gaz,
dont tout le monde entend parler
à l'époque, depuis quelques temps.
Le protoxyde d'azote.
C'est très connu,
parce que à l'époque,
on sait que c'est un gaz hilarant,
qui a des effets euphorisants.
Et c'est l'utilisation
qu'en font certains forains,
sur certains spectateurs
pour amuser les autres.
Qui rend ce gaz là très célèbre.
Wells est très curieux,
il s'intéresse à l'idée d'un gaz
ayant des effets sur le cerveau.
Donc il va au spectacle
avec sa femme Elizabeth,
ainsi que Samuel Cooley,
un jeune homme qui vient parfois
les aider au cabinet dentaire.
Elizabeth n'a pas envie d'y aller.
Ils y vont quand même,
ils s'installent tous les trois
au premier rang.
Le spectacle commence,
et Gardner Quincy Colton
entre en scène.
L'inquiétude de sa femme
Elizabeth est avérée,
puisque Colton qui cherche
son cobaye du jour, pour le gaz.
Parcourt le premier rang du regard
et s'arrête sur Wells.
Celui-ci n'a pas du tout envie
de monter sur les tréteaux.
Il a plutôt envie de garder
sa position de spectateur,
pour voir comment marche le gaz.
Donc Cooley prend sa place.
Et ce dernier inhale le gaz
que lui tend Colton.
Il se met à rire,
mais genre un truc de ouf.
Et l'assistance
rit forcément par ricochet.
Cooley semble comme
s'il était sous l'emprise de l'alcool.
Il déambule,
il est maladroit sur scène.
Il va même jusqu'à
tomber devant Wells.
Et en tombant devant Wells,
Wells voit la jambe de Cooley
qui s'abîme.
Mais genre méchamment,
contre un clou qui dépassait
au mauvais endroit.
Et Cooley, on a l'impression
qu'il ne sent rien.
Il remonte sur scène,
il continue à faire le show,
le bonheur de toute l'audience.
A la fin du spectacle,
Wells nettoie la blessure de Cooley
qui est quand même hyper profonde.
Et le blessé commence
à se plaindre de la douleur,
quelques heures après en fait.
Il avait rien ressenti jusque là.
Et Wells comprend
alors que la douleur
a été complètement annihilée,
grâce au protoxyde d'azote.
Et là, il se dit il y a un truc à faire.
Le lendemain,
il demande à Colton le forain
de venir avec une grosse
quantité du fameux gaz.
Wells inspire profondément
jusqu'à être au bord du malaise,
ça remplace l'oxygène.
Et demande à Cooley
de lui arracher une dent,
qui est pas en bon état
depuis quelques temps.
Cooley s'acharne de ouf sur la dent.
Elle finit par venir.
Et là c'est fou,
il y a Wells qui lui dit :
"Mais alors, quand est ce que
tu vas nous l'enlever la dent ?".
Il avait rien ressenti,
il n'avait pas plus ressenti,
que ce qu'il appellera une petite
piqûre de moustique sur la gencive.
Alors qu'évidemment
le travail était terminé.
La dent était
complètement arrachée.
Et Horace Wells venait
d'inventer l'anesthésie locale.
Un peu généralisée quand même,
parce que ça touchait
tous les nerfs de partout,
mais la personne
reste consciente.
Aujourd'hui, le protoxyde d'azote
est devenu le deuxième
produit addictif le plus
consommé chez les jeunes.
C'est très mauvais pour la santé,
c'est très dangereux,
les risques sont réels.
ça peut emmener jusqu'à l'asphyxie
et donc directement à la mort.
Donc on est bien d'accord,
vous et moi.
Personne ne prend
de protoxyde d'azote,
c'est une connerie,
c'est dangereux, ne le faites pas.
Est-ce que vous avez déjà
un peu la sensation
d'être l'ours
dans sa tanière,
qui se prépare à hiberner
en période de confinement ?
- Oui, oui, moi ça m'a fait ça !
- Toi ça t'as fait ça ?
C'est normal, parce que
tu ne crois pas si bien dire.
C'est à cause des neurones Q.
- Les fameux...
Des chercheurs ont fait la découverte
d'un ensemble de neurones, chez le rat.
Les neurones Q donc.
Et en effet, deux études publiées
par des neuroscientifiques
dans la revue "Nature",
ont montré que le rat
possède ces neurones,
qui lorsqu'ils sont activés,
permettent d'entrer dans un état
qui est très proche
de celui de l'hibernation.
Alors que précisons le
quand même,
les rats n'hibernent pas du tout
en temps normal.
Ni en temps mauvais.
Ils hibernent pas, c'est tout.
Donc il est possible
d'activer ces neurones.
Et en les activant,
on baisse l'activité du rat,
ainsi que sa température corporelle.
L'une de ces études s'est centrée
sur l'aire pré-optique médiane,
qui une partie de l'hypothalamus
dans notre cerveau.
En activant un groupe de neurones
pré-optiques, des neurones Q donc.
Les chercheurs ont constaté
que la souris se trouvait immobile
en hypothermie, avec
une grosse chute de température,
d'une dizaine de degrés.
En gros ça passait
de 37 à 24 degrés.
C'est un état qui est très similaire
à celui de l'hibernation.
L'étude parle alors du fait que
ces neurones trouvés chez les rats,
pourraient potentiellement
être présents chez l'homme.
On en est pas encore certain,
mais pourrait donc
être potentiellement activés.
Et l'utilisation qu'on pourrait
en faire serait très différente
de celles que font
les ours, les serpents
ou les tortues par exemple.
On pourrait faire
du transport médicalisé
de certaines personnes,
selon leur maladie.
Parce que des fois,
ça peut être délicat.
On pourrait faire
une hibernation temporaire,
pour un transport plus sécurisé.
On pourrait aller
beaucoup plus loin.
On pourrait également se dire,
qu'en utilisant ça chez les astronautes,
on pourrait faire des voyages
de très longue durée.
Comme celui vers Mars,
qui alors serait beaucoup
plus envisageable,
puisque la personne sera en
hibernation tout l'aller, tout le retour.
Dans le film Inception,
Dominick Cobb qui est joué
par Leonardo DiCaprio,
se rendait avec toute son équipe,
dans les rêves
de Robert Fischer Junior.
L'idée c'était de
déposer une idée...
Oh.
- L'idée, c'était de déposer une idée ?
- J'ai fait une "idée-ception".
Bon bref, il devait déposer une idée,
pour qu'elle germe.
Et pour qu'elle prenne vie
dans la réalité en dehors du rêve.
La psychologue Américaine
Elizabeth Loftus,
elle a réussi à introduire
de faux souvenirs,
dans le cerveau de participants
pour ses expériences,
sans avoir à passer par les rêves,
ni aucun autre artifice.
En fait, il s'agit de l'effet
de désinformation.
Dans le premier épisode
de cette série de vidéos,
je vous ai parlé de l'effet placebo.
C'est un peu la même idée
qui a été utilisée ici.
En effet, si on fait croire à un patient
qu'on lui donne un médicament,
il va développer la sensation
que son mal est soigné.
Ou tout du moins,
en partie soigné.
Concernant les souvenirs,
il suffit de faire croire à la personne
qu'elle a vécu un événement,
pour qu'elle ait l'impression
de l'avoir réellement vécu.
C'est un peu flippant.
Les participants à l'expérience
d'Elisabeth Loftus,
se sont vus rappeler certains
événements liés à leur enfance,
en précisant que c'était
des membres de leur famille
qui avaient fourni
tous ces éléments là.
Il s'agissait donc
de véritables souvenirs,
dont les participants
pouvaient se rappeler.
La psychologue a alors
ajouté un seul faux souvenir.
Les participants se seraient perdus
dans un centre commercial.
Et après plusieurs rencontres avec
la psychologue, où ça parlait de ça.
25 % d'entre eux croyaient réellement
que l'événement s'était passé.
Ils auraient pu le jurer.
Certains même, ajoutaient
des détails de tout ce truc,
où ils se sont perdus.
Ils rajoutaient pleins de choses,
alors que ça n'a pas du tout existé.
Et c'est quasiment impossible
de faire la différence,
entre le vrai souvenir
et le faux souvenir.
Sauf si vous trouvez
une information
qui prouve que le souvenir
n'a pas existé.
Une incohérence
de temps, de lieu.
Ce genre de choses.
Moi-même, je l'ai vécu.
Parce que je visualisais
quelque chose qu'on m'a raconté.
Sur un lieu avec des gens
que je connaissais.
Et j'ai cru y être.
Et la seule manière pour moi
de découvrir que c'était faux,
parce qu'on me disait que
c'était pas vrai que j'étais pas là
et que je disais que si.
C'était de voir que j'étais
en tournée à l'époque à Nantes,
donc je pouvais pas être à Nantes
et à Paris en même temps.
Mais c'est très flippant,
parce que le cerveau, la mémoire,
traite en fait l'information
de la même manière,
qu'elle soit vécue
ou imaginée.
ça part en mémoire épisodique.
Donc après c'est très dur
de faire la différence.
Par exemple,
dans l'expérience de Loftus,
concernant le faux souvenir d'enfance,
dans le centre commercial.
Il pourrait avoir réellement existé,
pour un ou plusieurs des participants.
Elle a donc refait l'expérience,
en insufflant à ses cobayes,
le souvenir d'avoir vu le personnage
de Bugs Bunny à Disneyland.
Et ça on sait que
c'est vraiment impossible,
pour tous les participants.
Puisque Bugs Bunny,
c'est un personnage de...
- Looney Tunes.
- Et qui appartient à ?
-  Twenty Century Fox ?
- La Warner.
- Pas à Disney.
- Mais qu'est ce qui n'appartient
plus à Disney maintenant?
- Pas grand chose.
- Au final les recherches
d'Elisabeth Loftus ont notamment
permis de sensibiliser
du personnel de police,
au fait que selon comment
les questions sont posées
pendant un interrogatoire.
Le suspect ou la victime,
peuvent être amenés
à se créer un faux souvenir
qu'elles croiront vrai.
En y ajoutant même
des détails au fil du temps.
Une expérience
du même style a été faite
et même filmée plus récemment,
par la chaîne de télévision RTS.
Je vous mets le lien
dans la description.
L'expérience s'est déroulée
en plusieurs étapes.
Un, ils ont réuni quelques
personnes dans un cinéma.
Deux, quelques temps plus tard,
ils réunissent les mêmes personnes,
plus Lola, une jeune fille,
qui n'était pas présente
lors du tournage dans le cinéma.
Trois, le journaliste parle
alors d'un faux souvenir,
il indique se rappeler du moment
où Lola lui a renversé du café
sur le pantalon juste avant
le tournage dans le cinéma.
Quatre, ils envoient par la suite,
des photos du tournage
aux participants.
L'une des photos est trafiquée.
Lola apparaît sur celle-ci.
Et cinq, ils rappellent les participants
pour les interviewer individuellement,
sur leurs souvenirs de la journée
du tournage au cinéma.
Et le résultat, là du coup
c'est plus tout à fait surprenant.
Certaines personnes
étaient persuadées
que la petite fille était présente
au cinéma, au tournage.
Et se sont créés des faux souvenirs
du moment où ils l'avaient aperçue.
Pour aller plus loin, il y a E-Penser
qui a fait une excellente vidéo,
hyper détaillée sur le sujet.
Je vous invite à aller la voir,
je vous mets également
le lien dans la description.
Merci beaucoup
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo.
N'oubliez pas de la liker.
N'oubliez pas de la partager,
si vous souhaitez.
De vous abonner.
Je m'appelle toujours
Fabien Olicard.
L'abonnement, c'est gratuit.
Activez la cloche pour ne pas
rater les prochaines vidéos.
Et ici je vais vous
en mettre deux autres.
Attends juste avant, je fais apparaître
mon compte Instagram.
Parce qu'il y a pas mal de choses
complémentaires à mes vidéos.
Venez, on y est très bien.
Voilà.
Et les deux autres vidéos
que je vous propose,
c'est simplement
l'épisode 1 et l'épisode 2.
De cette série des expériences
stylées sur le cerveau.
Si vous les avez pas vues,
passez maintenant.
A très bientôt,
Ciao !